हुआ था नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
सीखने वाला है काश है या पनियों टिप्स व
का नाम देखकर डरिए मत कि बहुत ही मजेदार
बहुत ही इंट्रेस्टिंग कंसेप्ट है मतलब
क्या कि आपके जो भी सारी इच्छा है कलपना
हैं सपने या फिर आपके जो भी अ मतलब जो आप
एक दूसरों सुझाव देने वाले वह यह सब आप इस
कंसेप्ट से दे सकते हैं मतलब फॉर एग्जामपल
आप सबको कभी कभी फिल्म का वह अमिताभ बच्चन
का डायलॉग याद होगा कि कभी-कभी मेरे दिल
में ख्याल आता है तुम होती तो ऐसा होता
तुम यह करती तुम वह करती अभी व है क्या
कौन सा टेंस है यह ना प्रेसिडेंट है ना
पास्ट टेंस फ्यूचर है कि कभी थी ही नहीं
होती तो होती तो विद ऑल इन रियल यह कुछ
वास्तविक नहीं है या फिर जब हम बोलते हैं
कि वही तुम्हारी जगह अगर मैं होता तो मैं
तो 19 उनके लिए मुझे पता है तुम कर लेते
हैं नहीं पता नहीं पर बोले को कहा जाता है
कि तुम थे कि नहीं होते इससे रियर सीट
है तो यह जो सारी सिचुएशन है वह हम इस
कंसेप्ट सीखने वाले हैं हम एक यूनिट से
पांच तय सिचुएशन सीखने वाले हैं और अच्छी
बात क्या है कि अगर आप सिंपल पास्ट टेंस
कंसेप्ट क्लियर है अगर आपका सिंपल पास्ट
टेंस क्लियर है एपिसोड टैन अगर आपने नहीं
किया है तो देखिए तो आज हम सिर्फ एक नया
वर्ग सीखने वाले हैं और आप यह सब सीख
जाओगे तो फिर कनेक्शन तो सबसे पहले देखते
कि बिल कैसे करना है कि हम बिल कैसे
करेंगे इसको कैसे बोलेंगे तो उसके लिए
आपको सिर्फ एक नया वर्ग सीखना है तो उसके
लिए देखो वर्णन तो आपको पता है ना किसी को
बैलेंस विल उसका पास्ट टेंस होता है
वॉर्डन गार्डन अभी आप सबको पता है कि अगर
आपको एपिसोड 210 याद होगा तो क्योंकि
तुम्हारा होमवर्क ऐसा भी वह जब पास्ट टेंस
में आठ और सीधा मजा आता है नॉरमल बिहेव
करता है मतलब क्या है इस और के लिए यह धूप
को टेस्टी और फिर यह है इस गुड्डा दो मोड
वूलन
बॉलीवुड इन सबको यार रेस्ट अपी जब हम उस
कर ही लिया है कौए करेंगे तो सिर्फ ऊपर
उंगलियों देंगे वुडन होगा और बाकी सब वैसे
ही कि वह आप मतलब आयोडीन टिप्सी इस
विरुद्ध फैक्ट ई थैंक यू डोंट ड्रिंक
पेप्सी डू यू अंडरस्टैंड समथिंग इस
विरुद्ध पिज्जा अश्लील सिंपल ऐड बाकि सारे
नार्मल आपके वर्ग ने उनके लिए दम सिंपल है
बैलेंस जैसे कमज़ोर वर्ग विशेष योगदान को
यूज करना है एकदम सिंपल अभी आपको स्क्रीन
पर दो टेबल दिखाई दे रहे होंगे अगर आपका
सिंपल पास्ट टेंस क्लियर है एपिसोड 210 तो
आपको यह आप इनको झट से पहचान जाओगे पहला
क्या है वार्न और हटकर टेबल और दूसरा है
मोड वर्क पास्ट टेंस में यह सब कभी आते
हैं हम इस पर ज्यादा नहीं जाएंगे अब जैसे
मैंने बोला था कि सारे मोड जो भी वर्ड
होगा पास्ट टेंस में दम मस्त प्रयोग करते
हैं हटन का सिर फट
में रखना है आपको दोपहर टेस्टी होगा यह का
बटन होगा सिमिलर नहीं यार अभी तो हिस्से
को यूज करने वाले हैं कार्रवाई के लिए
सिर्फ इनमें से जो वायरल हट अंग कौन
इस्टर्न और दुर्योधन है उन पर घुम लगाने
वाले और उनको क्या करने वाले हैं वह रॉनित
रॉनित सिंपल इंग्लिश में
है क्योंकि कैन यू गिव मी अ पर है अब मांग
रहे हो
की कुड़ियों की बुनियाद पर है और थोड़ा
फ्लाइट हो रहे हो बर्थडे निकला कि हमको
इतनी आदत हो गई इस्लाम को समझता है कि वह
गुड पास्ट टेंस बिल्कुल नहीं है कि मैं
अभी हम प्रेजेंट टेंस में है बट यू कैन
गेट कंफ्यूज जर्मन में वैसा नहीं होगा यह
जो नार्मल पास्ट टेंस वाला कुल है वह
कांटेस्ट अलग होगा और यह अधिकांश वाला
कांटेस्ट है वह लोग न एडवांटेज पर और बाद
में देखेंगे सबसे पहले बिल कैसे कर ना सको
तो समझ में आया देखो सारे जो नार्मल व को
टेंशन ही नहीं है बी रोड व गिलोय और सिर्फ
वायरल हटन और मोड ऑल वर्क्स को उनके पास
टेंस वाले रूप सिर्फ 25 है उनको उनके उम्र
लगेंगी डेट कंफर्म समझ में आई सबको अभी
इसकी यूज कौन से देते हैं अगर यह बिल्कुल
आपको आ गया ना यूज बहुत ही इंट्रेस्टिंग
है सबसे पहला एकदम सिंपल यूजर कि अगर कोई
इच्छा एंव इस बोलना और को लैपटॉप खरीदना
था यार तो होगा
इश्यूर डाइनर लैपटॉप कूपन और फिर इस
व्यूअर पेरिस बिजूका अंधी नकल दूसरा है कि
और इस मैंने कि कैन यू गिव मी अप इन थे
फ्यूनरल इन बर्लिन और थोड़ा लेट यू वांट
10 थोड़ा ज्यादा फ्लू थर्ड इंट्रस्टिंग कि
किसी को सुझाव देना है पर अपने पर नहीं
आना चाहिए तो तुम को पूछ सकते हैं तो
मास्क को पूछने को पूछ सकते हैं बाद में
क्या मैं पूछ सकता है मतलब दुग्गी टेस्ट
मार्क प्रांगण में तुम क्यों पूछ ले
इस तरह से यह तथ्य और इंट्रस्टिंग है कि
जो मतलब मेरे वह पुरानी सर थे वह बहुत यूज
कर दे किलोमीटर है 540 मतलब गुड भी तो
इट्स किंड आफ स्लैंग उसका मेनली यूज किया
है एसक्यू मीटर्स जाएंगे इट्स गुड भी हो
सकता है कि मतलब हो सकते हैं वह दूसरों को
फोन नहीं किया हो सकता है कि मैं उसका फोन
खराब वह लुक यू अरे नॉट फॉर मे रह ही नहीं
सकता कोई ऐसा न हो जाए और उसको घर से बात
ही नहीं करनी है बट हे गोट यह भी हो सकता
है कि मैं उसका फोन करा था यह जो आप बोलते
हो कि वाम नोट शोल्डर पर मेरा गैस है कि
वह ऐसे हो सकता है तो आप कैसे बोलोगे ऐड
क्यों निकल जाएं दार गाइड हेंडी एंड
डिफरेंट फैक्टर्स एंड तक संजय और अटेंड
अपना फेवरेट कभी-कभी वह चीज तो कैसा होता
होगा तो अगर मेरे पास पैसा होता
मैं तुम्हें पैरिस जब तक मैं पास कैसा
होता तो मैं पैरिस जाता तो अगर मेरे पास
पैसा बचा कैसे होता है इस होटल के लिए इस
ट्रैक्टर के लिए मैं पहले जाता इस विरुद्ध
पैरिस भेजो करना तो जोड़ना अपने पास तो
इसका कलर है यह व इस एंड द विलास पैलेस
में दुकान ₹1 का सेंटेंस वगैरह एंड वेनिश
क्लियर ट्यूबलाइज्ट एंड यू कैन एकदम सिंपल
है इस से क्या होता है कि यह थोड़ी सी हाई
लेवल की कंसेप्ट है इस पीस में भी वर्ड
जीवन के बाद आप यह यूज करोगे यह जब अपन
सिर्फ यूज करते हो तो आप यह दिखा रहे हो
कि मैं सीरियल की बोल सकता हूं काल्पनिक
भी बोल सकता हूं लटक स्वादिस्ट कंसेप्ट
इंपोर्टेंट और मुझे यह बहुत ही
इंट्रेस्टिंग लगती है रियल लाइफ इस कैंसल
ओके तो बहुत कृष्ण हम इस कंसेप्ट को
डिवाइस करते हैं सबसे पहले यह कार्रवाई
यूज का होता है वहीं काल्पनिक जगत में कि
वह यह हो सकता है यह हुआ तो वगैरह सब
बोलने के लिए हम यूज कर
कि बिल कैसे करते हैं नॉर्मल और उसके लिए
एकदम कोई टेंशन नहीं विलेन का प्रॉब्लम को
ऐसा सीधा रूप बनाओ इस विरुद्ध दुबई टेस्ट
लगाओ एकदम सिंपल रेट सिर्फ मटन वायरल और
मोडल वर्ब्स को उनके पास टेंस रूप और 1995
है उनको उन्मुक्त लगातार दशरथ क्लियर है
और उसके पांच यूज किया है कोई क्रीम देखते
हैं सबसे पहला और को लैपटॉप खरीदना था यार
इशू ड्राईनेस लैपटॉप कूपन ओके फिर एकदम
पॉइंट है डोंट एंग्री मी आई एम फुली के बल
पर तीसरा यूज किया है क्योंकि मैं खबरों
कुछ पता है कैसे सलाह देने मतलब क्या कि
मैं तो मास्क को पूछ सकता है
तो तू क्यों टेस्ट मार्क प्रांगण चौथा
क्या था कि व्वे चोर नहीं हो सकता है हो
सकता है रहेगा तो एप्स क्यों एंटर जाएं दा
इन हेंडी एंड इफेक्ट ठाट थे
है और पांचवा अपना कभी-कभी वाला अगर मेरे
पास पैसा होता तो हमें पैर जाता
बेनेफिशियल है कैस्टर व्यूअर्स के रिबन
एकदम सिंपल कंसल्ट करें मुझे आशा है कि
आपको यह कनेक्ट समझ में आई होगी हम मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धन्यवाद